how is it that they try and comfort or
reach out to their owners after they've
passed number one way is through dreams
and it's always positive so if you have
a bad dream that's not a visit that's
your subconscious working through
different scenarios a visitation from a
departed pet is always loving and real
and Vivid and you can feel them and you
can touch them and you know they're
there and when you wake up you're look
around because you're expecting to see
them because it was so real and that's
the most common way that our departed
pets will connect with us the other
thing that they do is they will imprint
you'll be doing something usually
something mindless or folding laundry or
driving down a familiar Road where you
don't have to be hyperfocused and in
that kind of mindless State you get an
feeling even a thought about them that's
them coming in saying I'm here I'm here
I'm here I'm good I love you